[Music]
now on tool hours on set dynamics with
his female co-host the secret to why
this show is on a roll right now is is
the relationship that we all have it
that was Matt just after joining the
Today Show full time in 1995 now an 11
year old clip posted by TMZ has gone
viral in which he can be heard making a
lewd comment
- then co-host Meredith Vieira when she
leaned over and in 2012 Katie Couric
made this revelation during an
appearance on watch what happens live
you co-hosted the Today Show with Matt
Lauer for 15 years what is Matt's most
annoying habit keep tension on the
[ __ ] whoever tracted to her
physically go America every man in
America was attracted to you even when
you wanted you've talked about this I
mean she's a very attractive woman cork
is not commented on his termination but
back in 2000 she said they had a strong
friendship we get along so well we're
like brother and sister he's the nicest
most considerate co-worker I think I've
ever had looking back on past Today Show
skits there have been multiple times in
which Lauer satirize sexual harassment
in 2014 he pretended to flash his
co-hosts backstage and in 2012 he acted
out being a victim of sexual harassment
at the hands of co-host willie Geist
somewhat look at this and say you did
something to provoke this it's
impossible I didn't do anything
differently I wasn't wearing a different
cologne it just he just this was
uninitiated
I mean why deny it I mean if you do it
to it
[Music]